ah Cinco de Mayo the day millions of
Americans celebrate by stuffing their
faces with nachos contrary to popular
belief it's not Mexico's independence
day but it is more than just another
excuse to party Cinco de Mayo
commemorates Mexico's underdog victory
against French troops during the Battle
of Puebla or 1862 but since then the
holiday has become a much bigger deal in
the US than in Mexico it gained
popularity in the 1960s and 70s when the
Chicano civil rights movement adopted
Cinco DeMayo to celebrate Mexican
heritage activist groups tried to
promote events tied to Cinco de Mayo but
they needed cash and sponsors that
opened the door to alcohol and food
companies that wanted to tap into the
growing Latin American market since then
Cinco de Mayo has been transformed into
the fiesta that frat boys celebrate
today